hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim okay I need a transom
oh shut up forcus Oh care how much you
need to train yeah all right
Begum oh oh wait of the guard don't care
douche nozzle
get out of my way blacksmith lady don't
claim to be the finest welcome in I
don't yeah that's nice
Guinea I need to get steel armor ah
known as steel armor you joking I think
inside there's more don't forget to
check inside the shop oh okay there we
are confirmed confirmed right in anyway
moving forward you're not thinking of
causing truck shot up welcome to war
[ __ ] not that beautiful yourself or
deal some damage protect myself I need
to check myself before I wreck myself
there it is that's the stuff yeah give
me that okay I can sell this Imperial
armor now oh I'm naked
what oh I should go around doing ways
this oh look how beefy I am oh so tough
in my birthday suit oh oh the problem
with the menus getting worse still can't
find a solution anyway there we go
ah at least it doesn't happen in that
many oh oh oh look how awesome I look oh
I look amazing okay now back out into
Whiterun
all right I'm going up to see the yarrow
oh yeah that does look much better
seeing you seeing how good an Argonian
looks ah love it
beefy with my orcish axe arm so tough
job so tough
what'd you say what'd you say lady yeah
that's why I thought you shut up no I
don't the first time I've ever been to
the cloud district shut up shut up on
rising as fast as I can
gah so many people want to yell at me
anyway hopefully I've fixed the
framerate problem everything should be
looking fine and dandy
I don't yes yes yes yes open there we
are this is where I need to be this is
where I belong
yes all right off we go hello gonna
fight me huh what meaning awesome I
don't wanna mess with me is not
receiving just shut up well that
explains why the gods like uh-huh come
on then the y'all will want to speak to
you personally
yeah no joke you better get out of my
way then don't mess with me
don't mess whoa lady were at algún yes
you saw this dragon with your own eyes
yes
oh yeah really you're certainly
forthright about your criminal eye
douche I wasn't a criminal your criminal
here you want to execute yeah yeah
actually now yeah what I want to know is
what exactly happened at Helga there was
a dragon let's see this seems more
important I don't care about oh right
Jarl Ulfric what do you say now prevents
momentous so it continued to trust in
the strength of our walls no against the
dragon yes my lord
we should send troops to Riverwood at
once yes it's in the most immediate
danger Bo I guess I should put my axe
away location he'll assume we're
preparing to join all four excite and
attack him no way you shouldn't have
I'll not stand idly by while a dragon
burns my hold and slaughters might be
that's more like it
here eleven send a detachment to
Riverwood at once yay go river winner
y'all for girder who's me I'll return to
my duties see to protect girder we best
well done vulgar ooh sought me out on
your own and was your own initiative
you've done wipe run a service why thank
you I won't forget it
all of these people speaking my Swedish
axles coconuts where there is another
thing you could do for me
mm-hmm suitable for someone of your port
gob blah blah blah go find far in
dragons my court wizard oh you're so
scrawny mater relate dragon look how
skinny you are MERS I'm good even take
me on alright let's let's walk cuz
you're gonna be head idiot and walk shut
up
shut up
far that's true I think I found someone
who can buying your dragon project okay
kombu dragons reach yeah okay all right
well when I say that huh that's not
really mean Dell what am I to the point
they I uh oh yeah I'm never certain
I've already got that find this tablet
no doubt it you mean this old stone and
stone of bleak falls Barrow yep
you already found it oh yes you are cut
from a different cloth than the usual
brute they are I'm cut from more than
cloth so what about my reward do the
oral about that vmsu word up damn it
gimme gimme my reward who's got my
reward
hello URL come back to yarrow give me my
reward yarrow
what what's going on yarrow not now shut
up now not now now not nice ugh
douche now what wait all standing around
is rubbish we should be taking the fight
to the storm club sure okay what I'm not
a man I'm a whipping in human form or
really just unsheath me and point me at
the end but don't even try me her on gar
what are we waiting for your kids what's
going on one of the new servants so your
left tells me you came from where you
live what angle abuse out here for my
love interest any chair me but with a
laugh he takes counter come his daughter
and she's a bloody blow that's right we
saw it coming from the south
uh-huh fast faster than anything I've
ever seen
Foster they native to it is it attacking
the watchtower no my lord it was just
circling overhead when I left
uh-huh I never ran so fast in my life
coward who to come off to me for sure
pansy good work son no bad work take it
from here boy head down to the barracks
for some food and rest had done to the
jails also notice the the breakout of
[ __ ] Guardsmen and get down there I
can't remember it's called nowadays what
did my men to mustn in the main gate
clever good don't fail me yeah there's
no time to step I want you to go with
Errol F and help her fight this dragon
he'll fight the dragon who survived
helghan
so you have more experience with dragons
than anyone else here that makes sense
haven't forgotten the service you did
for me in retrieving the Dragons stone
for far in God okay as a token of my
esteem I have instructed a vineet see
that you are now permitted to purchase
property in the city yes accept this
gift from my personal armory
okay come along I would very much like
to see this dragon that's my reward okay
I'm just going I'm gonna assume that I
can get there to find you and it'll be
fine okay um all right whatever
screw them screw them all I'm going they
can't stop me now no one can stop me now
code lock white men is there oh never
mind like a Peter stupid [ __ ] loads too
quick
let me Adam boring whoops swim at yo I
want to swim anyway totally meant to do
that
shut up pick flowers Oh lead epic
picking watch it three 360 Cup [ __ ]
alright nevermind say hell again got hit
by a driver alright yeah yeah a dragon
need to kill dragon I'm half dragon
myself in more ways than one hello baby
so I can learn numbers oh hello hey I'm
going to run an ensign you so fine
how's it going bit Oh dragon sorry
totally forgot about the dragon right
gotta kill the dragon got it kill
dragons yeah whatever whatever okay most
shops are open from about 8 a.m. to 8
p.m. if the shop is closed wait until
morning or pick the lock and break in
yes look at animal Argonian bartender
love the argonians except for that one
that tried to kill me but I don't I
don't blame him
alright um where's my marker there it is
okay uh up with short cut didn't hurt
alright hello oh look it's Khajiit
someone told me to play with the Khajiit
for the unarmed skilling look at stupid
the are Khajiit are
yes oopy they are stupid cat lizards are
where it's at
hahaha who cares about cat people okay
following the marker come on you pansy
run for I need to invest on whenever I
level up now I need to invest points in
stamina I can't stand not being able to
run okay here's a marker there's no one
here butterflies gotta go it's me some
butterflies yeah I'm such a manly
warrior come here come here come here
I'm gonna get you I'm gonna get you I'm
up
what ah rather butterfly come here come
here I want you I'm Okita I'm on Kucha
yeah I've got ya rip your wings off oh
it's just sitting up on that rock let's
sneak over oh what Oh what
Nach murder lies kill me good good good
good come here
stupid butterfly there we go
murdered okay another one forgot you
alright Oh kill them elk deer I'm so
slow oh oh I'm so slow oh I want to be
faster
dad dad times okay so what's the hell is
going on oh there you are
did I run way past it oh I must have run
way ahead of her oh wow gave me some
time to pick the flowers and chase
butterflies no one tell her about that
oh it's you elf
yes I'm dragon right now no kidding
looks like he's been here yeah so y know
it looks bad
we've got to figure out what happened
yeah yeah dragon is still skulking
around somewhere yeah
spread out I guess you're not so bad we
need to know what you're pretty fine I
guess I suppose
okay yeah yeah come on come on let's
find this dragon those dragons don't
exist
haha the space Corps Wow
land it over there I gotta go find it
space Corps yeah hahaha
a little bit of portal to interaction oh
and the answer people questions yes I am
going to be playing Dawnguard
okay talk to stuck trapped when they
tried to make a run for it I will do
Dawnguard make sure that gets put in
with drag quickly now I don't know I
don't know you know let's save us here
he comes again here he comes again
here he comes I don't have arrows I have
an axe
I have arrows but I mean I'm not gonna
use arrows I'm gonna Myrtle eyes this
[ __ ] with my axe well then yeah another
maggot
another magic dragon Rosie you land over
there where is he oh let me Adam
oh gosh yeah here we go mirror milner Oh
doesn't hurt doesn't hurt at all okay
maybe it yeah that yeah that hurts
okay maybe 4 to 5 my hell oh boy maybe I
didn't think this through
alright um
how about how about his skin yeah all
right yeah
Oh doesn't hurt come back little pansy
where it's going where are you going
come here come here
there you are yeah [ __ ] the hell out
okay I'm gonna go run away ah
that wasn't fair but ah back here doosh
doosh how was it fair
he totally cheap-shotted me no signs
yeah dragon right now oh shut up
looks like shut up I know it looks bad
but we've got to figure out what
happened
shut up that dragon is still skulking
around somewhere shut up
spread out look yeah yeah yeah okay I
need to know what I'm gonna be a little
more cautious I suppose I pose Maxim
I'll run out of time
bang boom
alright I'll figure I'll go look check
them out after I take care of this
dragon come on let me up there we are no
it's coming back wait
and you get all get back it's back here
somewhere somewhere and talk just got
grabbed when they tried to make off just
got grabbed when they tried to make a
pun where's this dragon quickly now I
don't know I don't know or I'll try the
longbow a bit Oh save us here he comes
again
he comes looking very calm actually I'm
going to do a mid combat cut that's all
the time I got for this episode thank
you guys so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next part
with this dragon bye bye